oh shoot at 50 that help look at how
luxury smooth goes oh you know if I have
big pan yeah honey he's been in some of
my videos we have a podcast it's very
exciting it's called the wiki cast and
basically we find a random Wikipedia
article every week and we talk about it
and we go off on tangents and it's
really good we talk about basically
everything other than the Wikipedia ask
pretty much yeah so we've just launched
this this is on our second channel
spongy and electric which simply might
be aware of what we'll be posting there
in the near future that we've got some
film reviews coming out we have some
Kerbal space program yeah we've been
waiting for that yeah and we're finally
gonna blow them all we've also we're
thinking of trying to really sort the
capture card system out for the
PlayStation and maybe get some more
stuff on there some more arcadey things
might be quite fun so basically if you
like the two of us together and why
wouldn't you
we are basically that's our channel for
us just doing stuff together
yeah film reviews game and any other
guff that we think I love or cast as
natural so if you like the sound of
listening to us like basically it's
literally just what we've been doing now
about half an hour at a time it is on
iTunes is on pod bean there's an RSS
feed which Dan set up yeah you're still
in the mid-2000s tell me someone's going
to use it because it was such a bully
but I'm if we haven't covered your
podcasting service of choice let us know
because we'll we'll set that up we you
know we've done a lot of fun doing it so
hopefully we're just we just want this
to reach as many people as possible
that's the wiki cast and a Facebook
group as well yeah we have a Facebook
page if you're if you're in your forties
you can like that and they're also gonna
be uploaded to Spungen electric if you
don't listen to podcast but you'd like
to use YouTube because we'll clearly use
YouTube you're watching this yeah this
is gold content in the best content um
yeah basically this is just a quick
announcement video saying that we now
have a podcast if you like us you should
listen to it and tell all your friends
about it all your friends every single
any parents grandparents
anyone you know anyone with a pulse if
there's that like random member of your
family the Year cornered with if you
have a look at aren't like this or like
family gathering you meet and it's like
oh yeah Alan really got anything to talk
about it like oh did you see that
ludicrous display last night this case
no not anymore
have you heard about this podcast it's
got the wiki cask it's an AIDS full its
wiki its Ricky its wiki
it's the best that's the kind of quality
comedy you can expect sort of good
thanks for watching thanks go in from
the podcast on your podcasting so as a
choice and if you like you can subscribe
to Spungen electric link down that bye
[Music]